wait wait prophet muhamad wasam he said
whoever goes to sleep and has no he
would who who do you make no no wait
wait whoan president he's my president
okay so then you can criticize him no no
no what you talking about you can
criticize by the way you criticize the
no no wait no no no no no no you can't
you know why my scenario wasian
president
wait wait I'm tell the you
miss he mentioned many which is general
for example said whoever has advice for
a leader not you leader for a leader
then take him by hand okay and
now okay who who the leader of
M no so what Allah told m
go to him and speak to him directly he
never said go
to go to him even not his leader because
leader adise
him by the way just want to something
between the schol of Islam by the way
between the schols of Islam throughout
the history in first in the first
generation by the way in the first
centuries of Islam that the school of
Islam it was never always one single
country they were always the things
never now what happened the scholars of
Islam they said you're criticizing
directly Your Leader the Muslim leader
they said it it will cause fitna in your
country the in the country that you are
in now there is difference of opinion
between the schols of Islam about
criticizing other Muslim leader but the
other one they say what is the point you
suppose I'm here I'm Jordanian what is
the point me to critize uh IM or abui
or Jordan he criticized he was he
was when he was criticizing
Iraq criticize or go
to when he criticizes the sudane rulers
in
I'm just
bringing you're direct again the SCH of
Islam they defer on this they said
you're direct leader don't criticize no
one
seconde by the way the other leaders
listen to me the
other listen the other leaders there's
difference opinion to to if you have a
leader for yourself and there is other
leader who's doing something wrong for
example he's not your direct leader
there is no for him so the point is is
the scholars they defer are we allowed
to criticize him or not there is differ
opinion so if I take opinion
criticizing second one second the
problem is the one who stand they said
what is the point suppose youze from
today until one year what's what's going
to
happen one one second one second even
for example as as you mentioned for
example for example you will never him
saying any statement for example about
about his leader because that's that's
the way of what we learn from him and
well he was literally advising the other
Muslim leaders directly and if there is
something which is wrong even he sent to
our King for example our late King King
Hussein when they wanted to make a
statue for him he said he said your
grandfather will not the prophet will
not agree to to build this so that's a
criticism and
he private private private private it's
not private the is telling you add words
don't add words you don't
know it was a letter yes people
published no no people it was a private
no no don't tell me I was wrong it was a
private then the people after they
publish the books and and for you to
just here the point is what is the point
here what we are saying what is if
suppose you criticize now what we are
saying the scholars they said no problem
if there's something wrong if you know
something which is wrong if you know
something which is wrong you criticize
for example I don't agree with this with
the with all of these things for example
about the treat the treatment or
whatever with the z i don't agree with
it but here in the same time doesn't
mean you're right we are right
criticizing no I criticized the ACT you
just did you said you disagreed with
what the rulers the are saying agree you
need to know I disagree with criticizing
they did wrong does speak my point is
again you did they do wrong or not to
normalize this
guy normalizing with is is Right could
be right when there is something and we
could be wrong we could be wrong they
could be right
rep Allah told us to go leers and SCH
who just Liber Lim we
just and I don't know any opinions I
want to check it but the point here is I
just give you a proof in the Quran Allah
told told told to go to even was not the
leader of M was but said go adise him
directly okay so but brother you digress
my point said whoever goes to sleep and
he has no on his neck he will die upon
you have no no no the thing that you're
saying is you have be to the
Algerian why can't you criticize why
can't why can't you criticize Saudi
ruler why can't you
criticize opin not to do it with he that
you
cannot do you saying he's doing of me
for what for criticizing Saud rulers
I'm
a am
am
time are you
a because you to begin with are you I
don't have I haven't made B to Saudi I
hav't made
you say
I'm because I criticize because I
criticize those rulers how does that
make
sense
me he Li he
Li and he lied he lied many times anyway
Brothers he from the point Prophet muham
said whoever goes to sleep and has no he
I'm
asking you the
question yeah no he doesn't
answer
with he said he said wa wa wa wa should
I be killed for being a you know the you
know the about the prophet about
killing you call me should I be killed
should I be put in
prison if I go if I go to should I be
put prison if the leader decides to kill
me that's okay if the leader decides to
kill me if the leader decides to kill me
that's okay the leader decides to kill
me that's
okay and the leaders agreed
alhamdulillah go
theader
decides I know
inter wait if I'm the you said that
the you the I said that not
intentionally you're unfortunately
brother you you have you don't have the
intelligence to understand you're
working for you're working no it's not
intentional I what you're doing is
effect effect that's a li a li ask a
question show you will not agree he will
not read his tweet read the LI that's
why I'm not on Twitter
the
let me read to you he said he said
secondly wait that secondly he said look
look look he said okay promote the study
of as a way to promote secularism bring
him here so
we secularism you know this a joke do
you agree the I don't agree with
that no muhamed I know intention I know
his intention he he made
a video he
put
I int of that the point this man in his
tweet you know he lies because no one to
confront him when I confronted him here
say by the way online Everywhere by the
way cover it from your brother why you
say way to him
the
title my humble advice to give these
title he I don't agree with what he said
most what he said but the same to
callone that's a big to sayone
are ask about
him
he said who said criticizing the ruler
said anyone the ruler is by the way by
the
way
know it's
different yeah if you go
to
he says
about as you can go back he said what
they do they sit in their homes and
promote
against
he
he mention
20 20 grps every is
schol
Scholars
he those who say he obey the Muslim
leaders he call them bootlickers okay
and he criticized Muslim leaders openly
and criticized with
okay
okay did he reel thefe no he re the what
did he do he
criticizing he was no no but he's not
agreeing Witham right not
with
some people will fail into this problem
into this trap to criticize and because
of criticizing the there are there are
compliations that applies to this like
for example me I'm I'm saying here the
other day a guy he said to me he said to
me are you are you agree with you Sout
king I said Subhan Allah you talking
about my king why are you saying Salam
he said he's doing this with I said to
him listen first of all when you say
this about the king or any any leader
what is the point you you are sitting
here you're eating fish and chips here
eating chicken and chips here and then
you you criticize them are you in his
shoes what's going on there and without
the treaty that he has and I will say
this and I defend that without the
treaty that between Jordan and them W
there is no single one you know one
Panadol what do you call it one single
pad will not reach them I know of course
but the point is we need to understand
there are certain things that the
leaders are aware of and even I will add
to this said to go back to the schol and
as well even the schols they have to
obey the leaders even the SCH even with
ignorance
even that's a point my point is now the
brother is here the brother he never
said all the he
never them I was going to ask I was
saying ask has he said that ask him ask
him I'm asking
you yeah go ask
him go ask bring him for all that bring
him bring him I was yeah call him call
him because he English of
course
supporting with him promote him
everything emotion
you not even a
verse R away said whoever goes to sleep
and he has no on his neck he would like
day of J I said to him what about you I
have a question this I have a question
on this I'm from Bangladesh yes and we
have a woman prime minister very secular
she has nothing to do with Islam she
calls us a Muslim yeah should I give
buyer to her go ask us not me what do
this schol say I don't know go ask them
I like this this is one second they said
no yeah right so so there are occasions
where we cannot give Byer because of
what they do even though they claim
themselves to be Muslims who said no
woman no I'm asking you
woman asking M who said no woman I
understand I'm real said woman should
not be a leader but who said if it's
been forced upon us to be leader we
should give do I even have to ask a
scholar already said already said about
if if a nation is ruled by a woman
nation is R yeah said her leadership is
not accepted he said he be destroyed
because
said who ever put a woman on the as a
leader the will be ruined yeah okay and
what do we understand from that we
should no before we go to to understand
that's my point we the best you to go to
schols but Muhammad saying no I have to
bring me schol I'm not scholar so I'm
not the best person I'm not going to say
yes or no but I'm saying that the point
here is as this person I will tell you
straight forward brother this guy lies
many
times
no no no no it's
not the truth wait wait wait wait are
you just saying he's not a Muslim
no the No No I Muslim
careful no no no say stay with the
Muslims very some people will take your
words wrongly the question shami sh the
question I'm asking when I when when I
asked when I asked him a question as a
influencer Muslims I wasn't asking a lay
person who didn't know anything about
Quran and like likewise when I ask you
or when somebody asks you about
something suggestions ideas in terms of
what's you do not I do not see you
simply saying oh go and speak to listen
to this and there you would give your
opinion what you understand from the who
give you from Quran and
Sunnah wait wait wait wait one second
one second are you saying are you saying
are you saying no one should ask shami
any questions about any suggestions any
understanding of what's happening on the
ground in terms of how Muslims should
behave and so on they should not ask you
at all or do you feel with your
knowledge of Quran and Sunnah from
the as well as your own learning that
you can impart some knowledge to the
Muslim youth to understand what's
happening and and and and and act in a
way that is appropriate and that is
islamically
acceptable okay the question we're
talking about here firstly I've heard
you you will ask about his opinion about
not any issue a greater issue the issue
of phe and the issue of the umah should
not you should not ask me what you can
say sh what the are saying me narrating
what the are saying that's not my
opinion that's why many times you can
check my videos when people says what is
your opinion is a Calamity that you
think sh should be speaking about this
big issues I'm tell you what saying
that's what I'm saying so you asking you
them what is your opinion about the even
though this
person I watch some of his debate no
Quran Sunnah there's a debate between
him and atheist he was 2 hours debate
I'm asking you about no no no I'm
telling you this person is not person
you ask him even me you ask me what the
scholar said I can't tell you SCH said
generally speaking okay but still we
have to go back to Scholars because
Allah told us that the fact that man
speak the leader speak about peace
treaty that's a
Calamity you have to agree with me on
the camera was it not wrong for him
interested in him
no people I asking about
this he said you know the majority of
the SCH ofl they said if the women came
into into power that there is no by
that's
aboutt or some they said if there is
because otherwise you know there no
choice in that's what I'm saying so so
people need to understand whether you
can give by or not so I need to know I
talking because I was talking about
if I ask you your opinion I'm not asking
your personal opinion from your own
desires I'm asking you you your
assessment of your understanding from
the I'm not asking you to give your own
opinion based on what Tony Blair says or
this understand what you're saying when
I ask for an opinion it means your
assessment and understanding of your
knowledge from Quran and Sunnah and your
understanding from the sh the scholars
and based on the assimilated knowledge
what do you advance
that if you say it's wrong then then we
we really in a mess because if I ask you
like this look if I ask you like you
like
your it's about your assimilated
understanding from the Quran and Sunnah
from the understanding and
interpretation of the that is the import
of my question so if you say are you now
going to tell me that my question is
wrong if you ask no if you do come to me
and ask me say what the SC are saying
concerning these great issues which is
issues to deal
with
okay
okay said but I believe anyone here if
you ask me says what is your opinion
everyone's going to think you're asking
my personal opinion you understand is it
not true
me let me
clarify let me clarify let me clarify
when we ask a Muslim in an influential
position I think misunderstanding when
we ask a Muslim in an influential
position look shami whether you like it
or not you are influential whether he
likes it or not he's influential so when
we ask an influential Dua a Muslim about
an opinion it's not about your personal
opinion as a professor of mathematics no
it's an opinion about you as a with your
accumulated and simulated Knowledge from
Quran and Sunnah from the interpretation
of that's how you will impart your
knowledge you're not going to say oh I'm
as a as a student of uh chemistry I'm
going to give no you will give them
understand so that's
how sta in your in your opinion maybe
that
case saying that's not right no I didn't
hear it they don't want to hear no no no
I said anyone hear
from I hear one
thing I asked him about evidence by the
way and that's why we need to understand
sometimes whatever you are saying you
cannot do it and you are a public figure
someone who's been followed by people
and then as if you're saying it's Haram
true mean if you say something is Haram
that means you need to have an Evidence
that's why because they call because
this is to say to believe something is
Haram it should
be point is that's why we have to
understand we have to understand in the
same time as well we need to understand
the the the side of the for example the
Muslim leaders in This calamity now if
you just put pressure eyes in the but
what's the what's going to happen after
that you just keep criticizing you
criticize from here someone will say
about sill out someone they will say all
of these things and then what's the
consequence the consequence people they
will be little them and they slowly
nowadays I could hear people belting the
status of the of the leers and as soon
as you see this it will be easy for them
to revolute Bea and he leared the
people in the even
I in
theing the in the past in the P where
where I came from in the past anyone who
even say bad bad word or something even
between people to talk about the king or
something that it's a big thing nowadays
you'll see people
normally and then what's after that will
be after that the cha
Bloodshed said yeah so that's why the
point is that's why we need to
understand even that's why when the SCH
who said even in the times of criticism
and I mentioned by the way earlier that
the difference opin about toze other
this is during the time of of the time
of some schol on both Sid saying was
wrong Etc criticizing him about this the
point is even though what is the what is
the point not same you know why because
that was after after
dur
about for example the leadership of and
all of these you know when when the when
what happens so there is two now there's
two party there's two party now some
some Scholars on this side and some SCH
on the other side but it should not
Beed even though it's a matter
of what I'm saying when we say when we
say again even the schol they said it's
I said to you the vast majority of the
scholar that it shouldn't be shouldn't
be done the point is is why because
that
lead before I go before I go before you
go let me say you will you will you will
because you're G to give a
instead
no he jumped on the opinion test show
you people Des what do he left the
majority of the scholars heum open he
say I says okay brother Muhammad he was
talking about it was
in that should not be utilized it should
not be utilized as a proof no me coming
from Bangladesh in which there's a woman
no no no no no no no no so do you think
I will be in the right position to
criticize her Allah ask not me I don't
know I ask that's a general ruling ring